I've invited you all to My Island hi
because tonight a murderer will be
committed
my murder I wish you're dead will we
still be able to talk to you yeah I'm
not playing dead the whole weekend dude
this is truly delightful Daniel um again
congratulations on the film I do have to
say
Logan lucky I've been like this is not
fair that you're able to impersonate my
Heritage this well but if I do it I hope
I do it justice I give it a go I'm sort
of Southern
you said it well who did you who did you
listen to though because as much as
people want to say it's a broad accent I
can hear the work and care that is in it
because it really is a delicate one that
means a huge amount to me thank you so
much for saying
um there's a couple there's a number of
people who are in there that I use very
early on just as references Tennessee
Williams is one
um there's a historian called Shelby
Foote
um and various other people that just
sort of like kind of just influence it
and then
you know kind of ultimately sort of try
and pick an area vaguely where I want to
be and then try and stick to it um uh
without being too specific either
because I I kind of want Benoit to
remain a bit of a mystery
um I don't really want to know exactly
where he's from what he's about he's
been many places I feel he's traveled a
lot so you know he's he's a not just a
man of uh from from the southern states
he's a man of the world as well so you
know all of these things so but very
very kind words very I tell you it
really means a lot of you that's what
you thought I appreciate it yeah Texas
and Alabama born and through and that's
what I actually noticed is he was a
southern person who dimmed it a little
bit and that's a careful different tip
to it which I appreciate yeah he's
probably lived on the East Coast for
quite a long time that's why I think
yeah he plays it up in situations where
he knows it's going to help
exactly exactly that's a huge part of it
um the other thing I really wanted to
talk to you too about it is it's a great
moment when in the film uh your
character is just so upset about the
fact that he's not maybe great at clue
Ryan was that based on maybe onset like
y'all playing that game or was that
something that you just automatically
knew inherently with had to be a part of
the Benoit character the fact that he
gets enraged by mystery king it's what
it's what Ryan fundamentally believes
I'm just a mouthpiece for Ryan Jones
after my ass now I just no I just like
the and by the way I should say it's the
the it's the mechanics of the game Clue
I love the movie clue but I just I feel
like anyone who if their job was
actually solving Mysteries would
probably be enraged that most people
think about this board game
yeah exactly yeah
well then Daniel I just have to ask are
you a fan are you not a fan I know you
guys played Mafia were you a fan of that
one
it was cool when I grew up it was called
cludo I don't have no idea why um in
England it was called Pluto but I used
to play it
um with my sister uh we used to play it
all the time so I know it very very well
I'm probably not very good at it anymore
um but as far as Mafia is concerned I
mean I had the best of times those
nights but I don't take those games
particularly seriously so and there are
some members of our cast Kate Hudson who
take it very seriously
heard I've heard before they get out of
here I do have to say there's tons of
incredible iconic women in this none
more than I think Janelle Monae she's
the avatar for every black woman of my
age I think a little bit but the other
one who was another black woman Avatar
gets a shout out from you in the trailer
of Mr Daniel Craig and that's Halle
Berry
I'm I'm just gonna ask like I heard
there was some ad-libbing and there's
just like a part of me that wants to
feel that maybe you suggested that they
use Halle Berry that's just maybe me
um it was me yes it wasn't originally my
idea it's a friend of mine
um and I just we we you know he doesn't
swear Benoit if he does it's in only
because of extreme circumstances so it
was one of those moments and it's a it's
it's something that a friend of mine a
couple of friends of mine I laugh about
sometimes and it's a good it's a um it's
in place of a curse word it's a good
it's a good it's a
good thing to say what can I tell you
it's a good thing I really dig that you
just made my year thank you and I'm
gonna say I shouted out Janelle Monae
and Holly Berry I got Pam girl over my
shoulder this is the perfect black girl
interview thank y'all so much interview
of all time across the island I've
hidden Clues you will have to closely
observe each other if anyone can name
the killer that person wins our game any
questions
Elderberry
that has a kick what's really
interesting with this is I I really do
love so many of the things that this
movie does I love how great y'all I got
to see it at Tiff and that was such an
incredible night but then I found out
something that made me a little mad and
I'm just gonna say it apparently y'all
did a duet of David Bowie didn't make it
and like I really like Ryan but I was
ready to fight him we found that out
like so just tell me about that moment
so I can visualize it everything we were
in Belgrade Serbia we we have been we
had been talking about what did it what
what when something was good between our
characters when the friendship was
formed and the partnership was formed
that led to the company that led to the
breakup that's the core of the the
history of the movie
we were thinking about we were thinking
about well
what what was it like when it was good
between them and we were just riffing
and I knew we're both Mega Bowie fans
and Janelle I knew Janelle had in
concert done covers of uh Daydream and I
said is that did you ever record that no
does anyone ever tape it no and I said
then I said well what if what if they
had an open mic night at the bar and and
we did moonage Daydream because I can
play it and Janelle can sing it out of
it so so we kind of pitched it to Ryan
and he goes
hey why not like at the end of the day
let's set it up and shoot a couple takes
of it so he gave us I think he was
indulging our desire to have the
connection a little bit can you indulge
mine and release it yeah I mean he
definitely has it in Catherine Hahn and
Kate Hudson are our backup singers yeah
okay you've given she's in the very 90s
wide shouldered leather jacket with a
funny Bob and I'm in uh I don't know I
think I've got a top definitely I think
I think it's fun here it's when miles
was thinking he's Tom Cruise and Last
Samurai oh I did I I do love the
timeline of this and you guys get to see
all in very different iterations and
that's all I will say without giving too
many spoilers but the one thing I could
say about Andy is you can draw the line
from brick with Megan good through every
Ryan Johnson it seems like there's
always a woman usually maybe
marginalized that is at the center of
his stories and she is a woman that so
many doubt Kelly Marie Tran is another
one obviously Anna like a woman being
doubted and just showing how Fierce and
awesome they are and Andy is that and
then on top of everything else he gave
you a lot to do with this so like talk
about this pitch for Andy and all the
things you had to do with her I think
Ryan roots for the underdog yeah I love
what you just said too we've been we've
been saying that okay that's exactly
what I think yeah is a real through line
that you gives his movies some real hard
at the center I love lets you know who
you're pulling for yeah thank you yeah
yeah you know I think when I read the
script I obviously thought about all of
all of the women that I've just know in
my personal life who have gone through
those experiences where you know they've
had a fallen out with their partners and
you know you're living in this in this
world where again your ideas are stolen
taken you're not taken seriously like
you come up with a short end of the
stick and I think because it's in this
murder mystery setting for me it was
just exciting to be able to play with
the complicated past that she has with
with friends I mean this person my
character is very wealthy as well so it
it speaks to classism but it also it
does speak to that like
you know that Underdog spirit that
you're you're rooting for and I got a
chance to just go go there you know I
got a chance to play I got a chance to
to tap into different Corners that I
necessarily I didn't I hadn't done I
mean comedy you know there is lots of
humor in this my character is funny
action lots of action there's lots of
drama the emotional deep like I'm
thankful for every role I've done up to
date because I don't think I would have
been as prepared you know what I mean to
take on something like this I mean when
you're sitting this is your singing
partner like you you have to come with
it I got to come if someone's gonna
mansplain to you uh yeah yeah
you got the right they're rapping me but
I do have to say toxic looks good on you
too and was this chemistry here for the
very beginning just real quick just
toxic no but the toxicity between you is
that chemistry like that bad chemistry
that's a that's that's uh that's us yeah
that's us mining our love our inverting
our love energy and and uh yeah no we we
no we we really like we bonded you know
just outside of this film we got an
opportunity to really get to know each
other the whole cast it was a lot of fun
at this point we are joined at the hips
yes and we're all going to be like
getting plastic surgery so we can be in
the next Knives Out installing it I hope
because you know we can't come he never
brings back yeah okay well I'm glad
y'all did this one thank you both very
much
always
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
is in plain side for at least one person
this is not a game
I will say both of your characters in
this are hysterical as I tell people yes
there's a mystery yes you're involved in
it but especially what you two do will
just keep me laughing through pretty
much all of it but I will say too it's
like with Ryan with this particular one
these two characters I love they put you
all together because y'all are in so
ways exactly the same but Polar
Opposites did y'all find that on set
like Kate what about you because I feel
like that's interesting y'all bring an
energy that is very similar but like in
this role you guys are kind of playing
on other sides of it what did you feel
about your two characters and how they
sort of work it's funny you say that
because and this well we're related
yeah but we definitely do there is a um
there had been something I don't want to
do any spoilers but like you're a
politician there's everything is like
everything you say is very calculated
and thought out yeah there is like a
pulp right there is like an inverse
thought process and there had been stuff
that was in there that like maybe is
still baked in there that's not on the
screen but that there had been of course
in the texture of it that their
relationship of course these are old old
friends and then yours is like no filter
it's like the opposite of political yeah
that's right but it's like we had there
had you might be picking up on stuff
that had that is deeply baked in there
yeah Moon and Sun is that what you're
going to say yeah and the jealousy that
that comes between the two yeah I mean
you know yeah very interesting I I mean
I think too it's like you know there's a
banter and a familiarity and then you
know what I liked about the all of the
group of characters is that even though
they're all so different you wouldn't
expect any of these people to be
together they did grow up together you
know and then they all kind of have
create you know
and they all hit on that one stuck on
that one person the disruptors we like
to say
um both of you I'm in love with your
filmographies and have them but this I
think is a is in a way a different look
for both of you this like Grand Ensemble
this big clue style murder mystery and
like I will always think that as long if
you can talk to me about rock music or
you can have something where you're
doing rom-com I'll be happy anytime you
can make me laugh or also do a rom-com
make me happy but is Mystery something
you'd want to continue doing is this a
look that you'd want to do because I
mean you did skeletons yeah I mean you
know it's funny because I I just want to
be it I just want to be in movies that
have great characters and great
storytelling and
um with people that I love to work with
you know and I I never look at my career
from the outside in it really is like
the the inside of you know what is
happening in the moment what's available
to you you know in the moment and
there's certain roles that I would love
to play at times that aren't necessarily
the ones that are coming my way and then
vice versa there's ones that are coming
my way that I can't wait to you know I
it's really about the writing to me at
the fall of my career yeah I mean
skeleton key was one of the most fun
films I've ever made and doing those
kinds of like Thriller with a great crew
and stuff it's so fun and then this
Ensemble too
was really special because everyone
really loved each other I don't know if
that happens all the time yeah I want to
get you a real quick response on this if
you have any are you a mystery fan like
now is that I mean this is this again
was something that I I I I there's like
hate like it's not like I have any sort
of grand plan or can look on the outside
and be like oh what's the next move it's
just kind of like what it kind of
unfolds I guess like whatever the next
thing is supposed to be and so this was
the next thing and it was like just I'm
so grateful for it because I didn't
realize how nourishing it would feel to
be back in an UNS in an ensemble
with a group of actors like I really
missed missed I missed theater and I'm
so this felt very much like that and so
I this was exactly what I needed and it
was so nourishing well thank you I'm
very excited for your next thing chaos
Agatha give me one word give me one word
I mean it's always chaos
[Laughter]
you're all friends
why would anyone to commit murder
are we even going to talk about the
elephant in the room
am I the elephant yeah you're the
elephant you're not that bad I will say
this is such a really cool Ensemble film
and I got the chance to see it at tiff
with the world premiere and seeing it
with that crowd was really incredible
what would you tell the folks as far as
like a murder mystery why obviously they
can see it at home they should see this
one because I do think this is a film
that really if you can see it with an
audience it adds an extra layer right
and I'll start with you Jessica or
whichever one no no no yeah I I love
watching these kind it's such a fun film
and I love watching it with crap a crowd
that is involved and invested this is
not something that you sit back and
you'll be watching Silence this is
something that you're gonna laugh out
loud and you're probably going to yell
at the screen so you want to hear that
echoed around the cinema thank you for
saying that as a like not talk to the
screen person but definitely like
exasperated yell at the screen I do that
you know and I'm not gonna let you
Madeline I appreciate you as a person
but there was a lot of my exasperated
screams at your character a little bit
she's fun but I'm just like this girl is
all right good I did my job I know it's
perfect oh that's a that's a great no
you were definitely one that I I feel
like an audience they're going to have
like she's one that they're gonna key it
on and be like yeah we have strong
emotions good at that you know to be
like I love that is that what you say
true like she's definitely somebody that
makes people pick sides yeah I I
sure look my my whole goal is just to
was just to make it we can't even feel
like any sort of like strongly one way
or the other I think that's kind of what
murder mystery movies kind of hinge on
is like people kind of predicting
innocent guilty like you know like so I
think the the goal is to kind of provoke
some sort of strong emotion I think
that's exciting that makes me really
happy and it also hides the mystery
sometimes because the person that you
may have this strong feeling about the
first time you see it you would have a
totally different opinion second time
around so as I tell people see it in the
theater yeah and then come see it at
home because you want to double watch it
but the other thing that I think is
great on this one is because of the way
you guys had to film it it wasn't just
the dynamic that y'all had on screen you
literally had to like keep it close to
the vest and Ryan told me uh so you guys
were playing mafia y'all were like
kicking it and like doing all the things
so yeah tell me about that the like
onset murder mysteries that y'all were
doing in the midst of this filming
yeah I mean we were filming during covid
so we weren't allowed to go out very
much so we had to entertain ourselves
and Kate is obsessed with the mafia game
I think she was the one who made it who
made the first one oh wow she did oh
yeah she did I think so and she like
she'd she would always like mocked my
heart
yeah uh yeah I love that one also too
you all have great scene Partners in
this I don't think anyone doesn't have
somebody that if you were maybe the
first thing on stage that folks are
looking at you want to look in the
background to see what the other person
are doing and both of you got to play
off of that I do have to talk about your
main scene partner in Mr Dave Batista
because I just feel this was such a
great look for him what was it like
playing alongside him who I just every
time I see him I think of him as this
and this is just not the look I would
have seen him but he does it really well
he does it really well we actually we
talk all the time about how like how
good Dave is in this movie
um and he was just an even better even
better
um scene partner I was really really
lucky
um to be working across from him and
then also just to be able to get to know
him he's so sweet and so generous and
um and very very thoughtful yeah and I
think that those are the makings of a
really really wonderful like person and
actor
um but yeah no he was he was awesome uh
we missed him very dearly he's not here
with us he's busy
this is so true
um I would say everyone again your
character I don't feel is like with one
particular person or anyone is with one
particular person but I feel everyone
got to play off of people like Catherine
and Kate in this one because they were
just so great if you could talk anything
about or any of the other folks was
there a moment that you really loved the
Ensemble we were like I just love the
fact that we together got to have a
scene in this
I mean yeah most of my stuff is with
Kate but really the the moment where I
felt that
um was during the dinner table scene
where we had all the all nine cast
together and uh getting to see nine
different styles of acting and different
styles of work was really Illuminating
and honestly it's why I signed onto the
film just to be a fly on the wall
I will say this because it is a murder
mystery is there one that you had going
into this one that you were like
obsessed with or was or was it something
that you came along with when you got
cast I'll start with you Madeline yeah
what happened to Princess Diana oh god
wow
I mean I'm gonna be honest we're
supposed to do here she said Princess
Diana and Lord
I've always wanted to know that's always
what happened you know girl you coming
with this what happens what happens to
the people on that flight girl
that is a really good one
I could keep going I don't I'm gonna
stop there no you guys are great being
an Earhart
and the other one
yeah where is she justice justice for
Bob what happened to Bob from stranger
things yeah where's
where's Barbara just got Bob dumb
years later the fact that the Duffer
brothers are still getting the business
on a Netflix junket I love you so much
what
thank you both very much we've arrived
disruptors have assembled welcome gang
we got a great weekend
Mr Trump I can't overstate my gratitude
to be here when's the murder mysteries
start I know besides you know Ryan
Johnson's knives out there's another
name that's really prevalent in this one
and that's Agatha Christie and I know
that like the way she goes to these
stories is something that you really
pride yourself on how did you sort of
use her blueprint in this one and why is
she sort of like the Godmother of all
the Mysteries you do well I I you know
grew up reading her books watching the
movies based on her books and
um one thing that uh especially in the
idea of making more of these movies one
thing there's a real Guiding Light is
looking at how I think people can
sometimes have a misperception that she
repeated herself and did the same sort
of thing over and over
the opposite is true every single book
she was Taking Chances she was rolling
the dice she was flipping the script she
was shaking it up in such fundamental
exciting ways that um you can see why
each new book was exciting to her
um and so I I think that's the main
inspiration I'm trying to take in terms
of this series is really showing the
audiences that this isn't going to be an
ongoing thing and just turning the crank
on what we did last time it's going to
be each of these movies is going to
hopefully totally surprise you in terms
of what it's going for that is the
absolute tagline you will be surprised
because even in this one the first time
I saw it and I'm like trying obviously I
feel like you've set it up now to where
everyone knows like pay attention and
you can't pay attention to it there's no
way to get ahead of this one and that's
the beauty of it but there is something
that I saw in common between one and two
which I do think is great which is your
commentary on the politics of class and
wealth and and the Haves and the
have-nots Really and I do think uh maybe
you and Nancy Myers there's not going to
be any bad location anymore there's
always going to be that is that going to
always be at the heartbeat of these
because as much as I feel are very
different I do think they're always
trying to at least comment yeah on the
problems of today is that true well yeah
absolutely I mean I don't know that
they'll always be specifically about
insanely wealthy terrible people it'd be
nice to shake that up but there's plenty
to go plan to go around it's true it's a
deep well to draw from but um but no I
mean it part of what is exciting to me
about making these movies and part of
the starting point for them was
um you know growing up just being a
whoduna junkie like nearly all of the
whodinas that I watched and loved dearly
were period pieces period pieces said in
England usually very disconnected from
my reality and so a kind of hazy
Nostalgia kind of draped around all of
them and that's not what Agatha Christie
was doing back in the day she was
writing to her time into her moment and
so the idea of doing a murder mystery
that's doing what Christy was doing back
in the day that's right here and now and
actually engaging with society that to
me is is also kind of the whole
launching point for this thing yeah yeah
what I think is really interesting
regardless of where you go next with the
third because we know I'm like
regardless of where you go I think we
all know that it's going to be murder
mystery and you're going to cast an
incredible cast like you've already set
that blueprint as well and this one was
no different but I just can't believe so
really you're getting Kate Hudson and
Catherine Hahn in them and Edward Norton
to play Mafia like Ed was in on the
mafia okay so those folks I say you're
kidding like so tell me about this like
I really have to hear about yeah they're
in like they're just as big of a clue
junkies mystery junkies I love it they
love it it's so much fun well I mean
yeah we were so the second half first
half of the shoot we're in Greece second
half we're in Belgrade and um doing like
all our stuff on on sound stages and uh
it was in the middle of the Delta Spike
so the covet numbers were really bad we
wanted to keep everyone safe so we were
very locked down in this really nice
hotel in Belgrade and so on the weekends
we to blow off steam we'd rent the the
bar at the on the roof and we'd all just
get drunk and play Mafia it was awesome
everyone was so into it everyone just
kind of cut loose and had fun I know
based on the premiere last night and
just knowing you you have some great
friends and I think everyone is just
waiting for when Natasha can get in one
of them oh my god well the thing is
though I'm doing my first TV show with
my channel so where where I don't know
man I mean she has a cameo in this one
playing herself a little bit Yeah but
I'm I'm just saying it yeah
mystery with her just showing up with
that Natasha Leone what oh my god did
she send you here did Natasha say is she
hiding behind that tree
so all right yeah you're right I could
do a lot worse